the mees family in the volkport time
district in rhineland-paladina
are in shock for days they have been
wading through the mud
trying to save the remains of their
cellar after heavy rainfall
the r river had turned into a raging
torrent and devastated everything in its
path
in fall we have rainy periods or melting
snow that sometimes cause flash floods
they tend to disappear just as quickly
as they come
but what's happened now is just
incomprehensible
friends neighbors and colleagues all
pitch in
the fire department police or technical
relief
have not yet showed up almost everything
that came into contact with the water
has to be thrown away the furniture
our drinks everything down in the cellar
was thrown in every direction
just like here
the water came all the way up to here
on the imagination as you can see
this is all useless now
the sludge reached every last corner
i just had a look in the cupboard what a
mess
i normally try to be quite tidy and now
everything is completely underwater
he hopes for government support the
insurance company has already informed
him that it will not cover the damage
too expensive meanwhile the livelihood
of thousands of people like klaus mies
is at stake the flood has swept away
entire homes
volport's time and neighboring villages
resemble fields of rubble
no one knows how long reconstruction
will last
on the night of the disaster klaus mies
was mostly concerned for his five
children
when the flood broke into the house he
had to carry his handicapped child to
the upper floor within just a few
minutes
i came down heard a roaring sound here
in the courtyard
and then i saw the water shooting up
from the rain inlet at the back
the whole rainwater system was full
now klaus's family is safe his office
however
is in shambles there won't be any
electricity or running water
for at least a few weeks
i'll have to talk to my customers and
tell them why our work has to wait for
the time being
all the computers are out of order
at least the grill is still working
a few frozen sausages were rescued from
the cellar
the people of allport's time are doing
what they can to stay upbeat